hello everyone and welcome to the recap
show of the sandler's rapid and blitz my
name is tatev abrahamian and i'm going
to take you to the highlights of day
one san luis wrapping and blitz is going
to take place over the next five days
three days of rapid and two days of
blitz so nine games of rapid and 18
games of blitz
you can see the 10 participants below
which includes the two-time winner of
the tournament
levon aronian ikaru nakamura previous
winner and the world champion magnus
carlson
so the chancellor's rapping and blitz
used to be part of the grand chester but
because the grandchild store was
cancelled this year it's a standalone
tournament and it's taking place online
so today the first day of the rapid
happened so three
rounds of rapid rare play and i'm going
to take you through the highlights of
each round
so let's start with the key match-up of
the round which is hikaru nakamura
versus magnus carlsen
so if you've been following chess during
the summer you know that these two
players
have a pretty big rivalry going on they
played an epic
match in the magnus carlsen invitational
finals which came down to the wired
which was decided in armageddon
they also just recently tied for first
place in the chess 9lx tournament which
was official random tournament
so once again they meet and this time in
the first round of the tournament
as a magnus carlson chose the karo khan
defense and
um the position gets quite complicated
so here he chose
to play c5 and this is where things get
quite complex
as hikaru decides to sacrifice a pawn so
he takes
runs back and he does not take back on
c4 instead he goes b4
and right away after sacrificing a pawn
he does not
um choose the right continuation
instead of taking on e7 and playing
knight g5 which he should have done
forcing g6 to the mate on h7 and
something like knight g3
and threatening taking on h5 and knight
f6 and attacking the king
instead he started with knight g3
and after taking and now we see this
poor pawn structure
and the pawn on a5 being isolated
so g6 and now it turns out that white
doesn't have as many attacking pieces
so knight goes to d5 on c3 and black has
consolidated and he's up a healthy pawn
and the pawn on c3 is
very dangerous past pawn so things go
from bad to worse for hikaru
as the pawn reaches c2
and there's going to be a really nice
tactic right
here black takes on g3 and
take it packs uh take back um as a
problem because of queen a3 winning the
rook immediately
and rook c7 and now uh finishing the
game off with a very
strong queen g5 a pretty um basic tactic
for a world champion but nonetheless a
really nice way of
finishing the game uh so a nice win for
the world champion starting the
tournament of
the victory with the black pieces so
let's move on to our next game
which is the game between wesley so and
jeffree zhang the two americans
uh wesley is a former u.s champion and
former winner of grand chester and
jeffrey zhang is
a 19 year old 2700 rated grand
master from the us a very strong player
and i really like this game is
because um i think it's really
instructive and i'm going to show you
this end game that was won by wesley
so let's start in some some kind of
position and then i'll take you through
the game to the chemo
which i think is a key moment so as we
can see wesley is
up upon and he starts bringing his king
so jeffrey decides to give up another
pawn hoping to get the pawn on f6 and to
make some kind of a draw
or maybe thinking that he has a fortress
of some sort here
so cutting the king over except that
this is quite temporary
as the king is going to run and we reach
this kind of an end game which i think
happens quite a bit
where um one side is trying to
run as we see white is going to try to
run
here and win the rook and black is going
to try to
take the pawn on h3 and queen their pawn
so it's going to be a race
and spoiler alert why did win this game
as you can see
and uh it was just by a temple which i
think why it's so instructive so let's
take a look
so the game follows a very logical path
so winning the rook
checking the kink and making sure the
pawn on h3 survives
and now rook f3 and
now um as black coins now a key move in
the game
king f3 uh the problem is
uh you would love to be able to play
kk2 make a draw
but the king f3 is a very nice very
instructive move because
you're going to take the pawn on h4 but
you're not just going
going to the pawn directly you're also
shouldering the black king and stopping
the king from um
getting to f4 and making a draw so i
think this kind of end games are quite
instructive because
it looks like it doesn't matter what
white plays because you're getting the
h4 pawn it doesn't
matter which route you go but
something like this would actually end
up in a draw
so those puzzles that we solve in books
that actually come in handy and can
happen in our games so i thought this
was a very instructive moment
let's take a look at our next game of
the round uh which was lanier dominguez
monsters pantala hare krishna
pantala hare krishna has played several
times in san luis but never in this
tournament
and he's actually making waves as he's
had a phenomenal day today
uh so let's start in this position uh so
the position was closed for a very long
time
and it still is not a lot of pawn
exchanges so bishop d3 was played white
takes
and now black takes the pawn with a
check and
i think maybe doming is hallucinated for
a second and
forgot um about an option that black had
of course he has to play king here and
exchange on d3
and instead he goes um
queen d2
and the difference is in the other
position he is down the tempo because
now black plays the very strong move g5
breaking apart the pawn structure and
now we're going to see how all of
white's pawns fall apart
and just taking every single pawn
so lanier dominguez had to resign
because he's just going to lose all the
pawns and that's the game
and our final uh game of the round we're
going to look at is between alareza
furoa and levon aronian
i'm sure otherwise of irish as a name
all of you have heard by now he is quite
popular he's made waves when he finished
second in the world rapid championship
last year
and uh he's a very strong player and
very exciting player
so um this game i think you're going to
enjoy a lot
so we have fuji with the white orange
with black
and the sequence is really amazing so
let's take a look
so white goes d5 attacking the queen
while his own queen is under attack
so takes on e3 takes on a3
so now taking on e6 so we have to trade
rooks of course
so now the knight takes so there's a lot
of intermediate moves so we cannot move
the bishop because
taken queen so takes rook and again
we don't want to take this because our
knight is hanging
so another intermediate move and again
we're not taking vendor c6 back on c6
we're taking on b2
and we're not taking back on c6 again
giving up this phone
instead c3
um so a lot of adventures happen in this
game i will just play through it fast
just to show you how it ended
which was quite heartbreaking for the
youngster
he just recently played in the chess 9lx
tournament and he suffered there quite a
bit
but he still was really grateful about
his opportunity to play the top players
and this game i just want to show you
the
final position which was quite um
heartbreaking for the young player so
reach this position says becoming a pawn
race
and maybe this is another hallucination
like we already saw one
in a previous game and knight d7 as
opposed to letting the queen
the pawn queen with a check and the
difference is not the black pawn is
going to queen with a check
ending the game so a really
heartbreaking way of losing for um
young alireza
but it is a quick quick game and this
was already in time scramble so
things like this to happen even at the
highest level and the game between
alexander krishna can you end up nipping
and eternal drama uh so let's move on to
the
next round so next round only saw two
two decisive results and one of them
was quite heartbreaking
uh so in this game between magnus
carlsen and yan independency i'll just
go to the final position
uh so let's take a look in this position
uh so if we look here
uh it says zero one so it's kind of
mysterious and the commentators were
also surprised because they thought
maybe it's a glitch or you know
uh the server didn't record the score
correctly or something
and then we later found out that he
actually uh flagged so
magnus carlsen he uh disconnected for um
i don't know he had 35 seconds he
disconnected he could not connect on
time and
he lost the game which is you know one
of the pitfalls of playing online
but this is the option we have right now
so it was really unfortunate and it's
very difficult to see things like this
because i don't think anyone enjoys
seeing the top players lose like this
but and i'm sure the player himself he
was very disappointed and
um because at this point the game was
quite crazy but at this point the dust
had settled
and just to loose like this it's kind of
like a pointless way of losing the game
uh
so this was how this game ended and the
other game was between levan el ronyan
and alexander krischuk and that game was
absolutely crazy
i will take it to the key moment uh so
this looks like some
kind of a bango or maybe some banani
something kind of crazy but it was
actually an f3 nimzo
so queen h4 was played and
not a lot of uh good moves here for a
white so the he decides to run away
because you cannot go queen f2
and g3 runs into some unpleasantness
here
so he decides to go king d1
offers queen exchange of course not
going to trade
king h8 threatening f5 not a very
mysterious move trying to
open the position blast open
so going for it and grishik was playing
an amazing
game until um i will show you
the key moment where he blundered so he
takes the pawn another intermezzo with
him
and here he took on d4 and actually has
an amazing
scoring c4 and asking what this rook is
going to do with itself
and rookie 1 runs into simple rookie one
cannot take
because of the skewer
and cannot take with the queen because
of
the double attack and now everyone's
hanging and this king is not going to
survive for too long
instead he took on d4 which is very
understandable
rook a8 cannot touch the rook because
the queen will go on e2
but unfortunately rook 8 was a mistake
because queen f2
and this is a very difficult move to
face because
it feels like uh black has stopped out
for the
end game because now your rook is
hanging and the queen is hanging
he still had the chance of playing queen
g6 and
eyeing this square because this doesn't
work out quite well
and now we can try rookie two we can't
take and
this is not going to be very pleasant
instead in the position he traded queens
and he went for this end game so i'll
kind of fast forward it
because um this position was played for
a very long time so it was supposed to
be a draw
was very close to a draw except we
reached this position
uh someone will look at this position
whenever you have a corner pawn
you have to look at your bishop so of
course white is up a pawn white is
playing for a win
but all black has to do is give up this
bishop for the pawn and just run to the
corner
so black has to play h4 and
uh stay in the square of this pawn so at
the opportune time he can run to h8 to
the corner
and not allow this part suspicious in
any way to get traded
instead he made a big mistake of playing
bishop c6 which again feels like a
natural move
except after king c5 h4 now fixing the
pawn on h5 now there's
a target in a position and now this
bishop is going to get harassed
the starks were a bishop so the king
runs to the pawn
so we're chasing the bishop away so the
bishop has to stay on the diagonal
otherwise the pawn is going to
start rolling so now we trade pawns and
now we reach this position
and now you i'm going to take it to the
rest of this game and show you how
this is just the winning end game the
king is so far away and the bishop is
going to end up on the wrong diagonal
which is a short diagonal
so pushing the pawn pushing the pawn
more
the bishop has to go there because if
you go here you get kicked off the
diagonal
but now king c7 and bishop b5
and i do feel like this was a
heartbreaking loss for alexander
christchurch because he had a great
position he had a great attack he was so
close and he just you know queen f2 and
he kind of um
fell apart a little bit and just
everything went downhill
this game should have ended in a draw at
some point but just things
you know when it rains i eat porous so
just things just keep getting worse and
worse and
he had um to resign in this position
uh the rest of the games ended in a
drone there are pretty quiet games
hare krishna versus feroza jeffrey zhang
versus linear dominguez
and hikar nakamura versus wesley saw
so let's move on to round three because
we had a very exciting round there
so let's get started with the game
between alexander grishog and pentalahar
krishna
so i've been telling hare krishna
actually after winning this game
he is one of the co-leaders so we saw
that
eleven arminians won two games in a row
and
pantala hari krishna actually managed to
keep pace with him
so let's jump to move 36 and
clearly alexander grisham did not have a
good day today
so this position if you look at it is
quite crazy this bishop is obviously
a goner but there's a pawn on a6 which
is very difficult to stop so he made the
big mistake of playing rookie 7 which is
such a natural move to get the rook out
of the way
make a7 the next move push the pawn
create some counter play
instead he should have done king f1 so
this is a very it's a computer analysis
which is very hard to find very hard to
make a lot of sense out of unless you
see it unless once you see the computer
analysis you can make sense out of it
but finding it yourself i think it's
very difficult
and the point being now this pawn is
becoming unstoppable
and like if you can
continue um engine suggestion this is
what the engine suggests just to repeat
the position
make a draw again very hard to find very
hard to do
because for example if we go a7 instead
if i just follow let's make some logical
moves
so we can take or we can take on c6 so
instead we should repeat again
with no time on the clock and this
complicated position
um who's going to find things like this
instead rookie 7 was played
but now takes and now there are some
checkmating threats and unfortunately
this knight
is overworked because defending the rook
defending
the pawn not the rook is awkwardly
placed so now there's a lot of
miscoordination
and there comes checkmate to blame him
for missing this checkmate there wasn't
really much to do in the position
position was already very tough and a
nice win
for penta lahari krishna who scored two
and a half points out of three
i'm just joined by um levon aronian who
drew his game
uh so let's take a look at our leaders
game he was playing hyun nippon that she
uh was a very complicated great game was
a very crazy game
uh so at some point uh i i feel like
levon started losing the threat of the
game and he decided
no more of this i'm going to
build some kind of a fortress which is
what he said in the post-game interview
so in this position he takes on b3
and puts a pawn on a5 and a bishop on g5
so the game continues
he actually gives up this pawn at some
point
and start taking other pawns
and this game just sends in the drop
because opposite color bishops and
there's just no way to make progress
there's just no way to um do anything
because if you
push this pawn
there's not even too much that white has
needs to do here to make a draw we can
put a bishop on c4 and the king on c2
for example if we make moves
something like this and we can just wait
and just a fortress
so the game ended in a draw so now hari
krishna and
levon aronian are tied for first place
uh so
let's take a look at some other exciting
games this was somewhat
um somewhat of a quiet round uh
there were a lot of draws so there was
uh only this one uh
decisive result there could have been
another one between dominguez and hikaru
nakamura unfortunately uh linear de
minges dominguez plundered and in a
winning position which i'm sure was a
huge disappointment for him so let's
start in this position
ikaru just played a5 and
another thing we see in textbooks that
happened in the game
take on b6 so we cannot go b7 yet
because of the fork
so the king comes back to stop the pawns
takes another pawn now there's too many
past puns for black to deal with
so he makes a mistake of putting his
king on c3
putting himself in this fork instead he
should have gone to b1
and now he um he really needs to push
this pawn because this knight is
untouchable
the pawn will just run instead knight d3
is just a blunder
and losing this key pawn and now the
king is way too close to all these pawns
and let's take a look how all of these
pawns just drop
and giving up the knight and just
forcing the drum
so could have been a really nice victory
for linear dominions unfortunately it
ended
in a draw and another exciting game we
had with was between the two teenagers
alireza firuja and jeffrey zhang so this
game
was something it was um
a lot of complications
so let's jump to the key moment in the
game which is on move 28.
so jeffrey zhang plays knight f6 and
furious decides to stick here 95 and he
doesn't do anything about his queen he
simply takes on the 8
and we reach this position which uh
looks um
okay let's make another move and we
reach this position which looks um
pretty bad for black because it looks
like this knight is not going to survive
here because the queen is just so
disconnected the square is not available
uh so here uh elerezar decides to play
rook d7 but
um it looks like after rook d8
something like this looks quite
dangerous this knight is getting stuck
and you can just start taking pawns
and you have to go g5 of course because
g6 is not possible and the threat is to
come and take
so rookie seven was played f4 looking
for some counter play whenever there's a
queen
we're looking at a wicking cannot take
back this way
there's queen g4 so who goes to f7
threatening mate
queen blocks cannot take on c4 there is
still mate
at f6 great move solves the problem of
tonight and of the weak king
so e4 and other reza decides it's time
to go for a draw
and the two teenagers through their game
which was very exciting game and
you know a lot of complications a lot of
things to analyze if you want to take a
closer look at it another game that was
left is between wesley so and magnus
carlsen west also with the white pieces
was too solid and
the game was pretty even throughout and
the world champion was not able to
bounce back from he's disappointed in
the previous round
so these are just the highlights if you
guys want to take a closer look
uh you can take a look at the games on
usjams.com
you can analyze the games yourself what
i would encourage you to do and make
sure you're tuning in tomorrow for day
two of three more exciting rapid games
of the saint louis dropping and blades
you can check it out on usgs champs or
on st
louis youtube channel thanks everyone
for tuning in